who is the all-time rom-com queen Julia
Roberts or Sandra Bullock who is better
at showing us the meaning of true love
[Music]
here's our round by round breakdown
round number one is box office round
number two is tomato meter round number
three going the distance and we'll have
a wild card round then you dear viewer
you will determine our winner
both are worthy but only one shall wear
the crown she's a natural redhead round
1 box office Julia Roberts made the most
of her head start on Sandra Bullock as
her highest-grossing rom-com flick
adjusted for inflation is of course
pretty woman the movie that taught every
young lady to dream big and promise
every rich guy that love could be
outside on Hollywood Boulevard it's
still her highest-grossing hit period by
contrast Sandra put up impressive
numbers with her biggest rom-com film
the proposal however her all-time hit in
any genre is the decidedly unromantic
gravity that's kind of sort of romantic
it's a love letter to space I guess
comedy yeah
julia has the numbers ever in her favor
all her movies have grossed a combined
8.8 billion dollars to Sanders
impressive total of five point seven
billion dollars and in this specific
world of rom-coms Julia wins again with
a total of 4.4 billion to Sanders 2
billion how much was Richard Gere's net
worth and pretty woman an obscene amount
of money anybody how obscene in about 20
were you talking about just profane or
really offensive really offensive I like
him so much
Julia also wins the pur romantic movie
average with her love fest doing 261
million dollars at the worldwide box
office on average
Sandra's is nice at 168 million dollars
but no Julia so if you asked me who has
the hotter career right now at this
exact moment maybe I'd take Sandra but
we're going on all time numerals here
and so Julia Roberts you win this round
and you're in the early lead round 2 the
tomato meter
these ladies are stars for many reasons
not the least of which is when they
commit to a role they deliver
each one has an Academy Award on their
shelf
neither one went for a rom-com though
what and they have some impressive films
that rank high the tomato meter Julia's
best effort is a tie between Wonder and
Erin Brockovich at 84% and her hives
romantic comedy is Notting Hill with 83%
and also toss in the Julia Roberts does
have that current streaming series
homecoming it's certified fresh' at 98%
but that's not quite in the romantic
genre it's not a homecoming dance I do
not believe it's not a homecoming dance
big mistake big huge Sandra has the
highest ranked movie of either
entertainer with gravity that's an
out-of-this-world 96% and her best
effort in the world of rom-com was not
the proposal no it was the film that
made her a contender in the first place
while you were sleeping remember that
movie she pretends to be the fiancee of
a guy nekoma
and then she really ends up liking his
brother who would go on to be the best
movie president ever Philip Pullman now
that may sound crazy but Sandra Bullock
made us buy it so that's why it's 80% of
the tomato meter is not good but the
whole picture of the tomato meter isn't
quite as rosy Julia Roberts's average of
all of her romantic comedies on the
tomato meter is 46.5%
huh and it's even rougher for poor sandy
her average is 31% I for the life of me
can't imagine a movie so bad and weighs
down classics like while you were
sleeping in the proper weight all about
Steve yeah that's bad that is bad all
about Steve is historically bad look I
know the tomatoes were either fresh or
rotten but all about Steve that movie
deserves no veggies of any kind period
[Music]
I'm gathering myself oh it's so bad well
Julie is gonna take this round too she
certainly had some assistance from Steve
but I really went into this thinking
their scores would be reflective of two
people who won our hearts at the movies
if they did it ain't on the tomato meter
point round Julia holy [ __ ] round three
titled going the distance and this is
where Sandra Bullock begins her comeback
who really wants it this category is all
about which actress covered more ground
tried harder did whatever it takes to
fall in love rom-coms make us believe
that if you really love someone no
distance is too great to cover is it
true probably not but Sandra gave a hell
of an effort we mentioned her nuttiness
and while you were sleeping in the movie
practical magic she sent a leaf on a
mission from Massachusetts all the way
out to Arizona and the guy got the
message way out there that's tough
that the lake house she has to put notes
in a mailbox that time travel back and
forth so that she can communicate with
her boy Keanu Reeves and then we'll
spring up all about Steve again because
why not she stalks that guy all over the
country which coincidentally is how far
I will go to avoid ever having to think
about that film again hey where do I
begin Hartman for the love of God stop
panic you look like a tease nip so
Bullock has a big lead in this round but
Joey has some highlights in the Mexican
she road trips with Brad Pitt to Mexico
Las Vegas and in duplicity she jet sets
the various exotic locations for Clive
Owen but none of those involved letters
at time travel in a mailbox to Sandra
you're on the board you're back in the
game you're taking the round
now we arrived at the wild card round
Julia's got a two to one lead but a wild
card round is who has the best romantic
lines two very different styles in this
round Sandra Bullock does not beat
around the bush she's very blunt and to
the point
exhibit a speed she says that's blunt
for something a little more rom-com II
how about the famous song from Miss
Congeniality
you think I'm gorgeous you want to hug
me
you wanna love you want to you want to
smooth me you want to and I don't have a
career anymore well played Sandra but
it's nothing you're ever gonna see on a
Hallmark card come on we want some good
romantic lines which is why we get to
Julia Roberts now like Sandra Julia can
be pretty direct like a pretty woman she
says I appreciate this whole seduction
scene you've got going but let me give
you a tip I'm a sure thing we get it
Julia but then she can also shift into
memorable romantic comedy speech
territory if I may recite from Notting
Hill and don't worry I'm not gonna sing
this time and don't forget I'm also just
a girl standing in front of a boy asking
him to love her no Oscar Julia wins the
round not just for that speech it's for
this closer from Steel Magnolias
wonderful that's in special so there you
have it my pick for best rom-com queen
of all time meg Ryan Oh meg Ryan enters
oh we didn't see that coming come on
Sleepless in Seattle you've got mail Joe
versus the volcano Top Gun in the cut
hey not in the cut but Julia you're
really the winner Julia Roberts wins
Julia Sandra because I know you're both
watching I'd say both you ladies have
given us much more than 30 minutes of
wonderful over your stellar careers and
this vid has been a few minutes of your
life you're never gonna see again bye
you can make it worth your while right
now you can vote in the comment section
right now leave a comment tell us who
you think is the all-time rom-com queen
in your eyes in your Marc Ellis comeback
for future episodes in your eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]